you
do difficult things the most important
thing
for your self-confidence for your
self-love for your self-respect
is to teach yourself that you do
difficult things
if you come up against something that's
difficult and you run away
you're telling yourself that you suck
and you start building the habit
of running away it's time to stop
running away and go
through why because you do
difficult things so i've got a strategy
called bando doritos and somebody was
asking me about this live on my
instagram today why do you have this
giant bag of doritos in your office
let me get it right here
why have this giant bag and this is a
big bag look at this look at this side
this is next to my head this isn't some
when you see it in the background you
see it you think it's some
tiny little bag but this is a giant bag
of doritos why
this is a reminder for myself that i do
difficult things now i'm a little bit
weird duck
you have to this is this is level 201
stuff this is advanced class
right now when someone is on a diet they
say get rid of the junk food from your
house right
clear all the junk food on your house
this is this is the advice everybody
gives
everybody get the junk food out of your
house so you're not
tempted in my head i hate that
i hate that i hate making decisions that
make me feel weaker
i hate making decisions that make me
tell myself that i suck what
what you're effectively telling yourself
is you can't handle it
you don't have the discipline you're not
capable
so we're going to remove the temptation
the fact that that's even a possibility
means i have to do it you teach yourself
you do difficult things
so i have this bag of doritos because i
want to eat this all day long
i might drool on this table right now i
want to i want to eat this bag of
doritos
it's it looks delicious
but i'm not going to and it's here as a
constant reminder
of how awesome i am that's that's the
voice inside my head
every time i see this bag of doritos and
i don't need it it's a it's a
it's a pat on the back it's a high five
to myself that i'm awesome it's a
reminder that i do difficult things
and people say well doesn't your
willpower decline like don't you just
eventually want to open it
like i i don't see it that way i get
stronger the more i look at it
the more the conversation is i'm amazing
i'm amazing i'm amazed and i'm amazing
and the less willpower i need because
we're building the muscle
of doing difficult things the worst
thing you can do is teach yourself you
come up against something difficult
right like oh doritos
oh i can't be here oh i gotta throw
those away oh i gotta get out of this
room oh i gotta go do something
you're running away and ultimately you
lose if you keep running away i remember
i had one guy show up to my thought
leadership
workshop in toronto and he opened a bag
of doritos and it's my favorite doritos
the sweet chili the sweet chili ones um
you can't get them this big
the purple bag black bag in the u.s and
he opened it up
and uh he's like hey evan do you want to
doritos i don't know if he knew about
this dangerous strategy or not
but he he gave me the back said no man i
can't i'm not having doritos right now
but
i took his bag brought it to my face my
mouth is watering
took a deep breath in
oh just the the smell of doritos and the
sweet chili heat and
um it's like i can almost taste it
as my whole body was having a reaction
to this smell
i'm gonna give it back to him thanks for
the offer man appreciate you
the i can't express how great
that felt for myself
and i keep doing it you know going down
candy aisles if you've seen my instagram
stories uh you might see me yelling at
the candy i'm stronger than you
jujubes sour peaches fuzzy peaches sour
kids
i'm stronger than you cookies butter
tarts
that may seem a little crazy a little
extreme i'm not suggesting you have to
go to the grocery store and
start yelling at the food although it
might be therapeutic and helpful
but the message to teach yourself that
if somebody gave you
a bag of your favorite treat that you
really want to eat
or if somebody was messaging you on
facebook
or whatever the equivalent is for you
that you feel like
you don't have the discipline that
you're not good enough that you need to
just cut off access to it
right that i can't be around my pho i
can't be around my phone all day because
of this
there it is right there all day long
just because just because
to teach yourself that you do difficult
things is one of the greatest things i
think you can
ever give yourself you might need to as
a one step
have a crutch right if you break your
leg you have you have crutches but the
goal is to then
run again because what's going to happen
if i get rid of the doritos
as soon as i go on vacation or i go out
to dinner or
office party or i'm on a cruise what's
going to happen i've taught myself that
i have no self-control
that i can't i can't do anything unless
i'm in my perfect bubble of an
environment
and i'm going to destroy all the food
because you've taught yourself that you
suck
i want to flip it i want you to stop
running away
i want you to run right into the thing
and show yourself that you do difficult
things
now i have a three-step process that i
want to teach you that's going to help
you apply it to your life
but before that if you want to have
unstoppable confidence and motivation
check out my 254 series they're free
the links are joined on the description
below you might want to get honest with
yourself
like instead of doing this i don't want
to be a millionaire
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
in order to get to the next level in
your business you got to decide right
now
what habits do you have as a leader
that you have to change now okay how do
we do it how do we stop running away and
teach ourselves that we do difficult
things
three steps let's go step number one is
damn the doritos find your own version
find your own equivalent of what damage
readers is for you so my friend mark
drager
uh for him it's the peak cream cookies
which i love too those those um
raspberry cookies with like the the
cream in the middle
so he's got those in his office a friend
of mine liron
wanted to get rid of having sugar in his
coffee so
he got a cup of coffee put it on the
saucer
and put two packs of sugar on the saucer
and he just started
drinking the coffee looking at the sugar
drinking the coffee and his wife thought
it was nuts but
in his head it's like oh my god i'm
doing it i'm amazing i can be around
this
right it might be it might be your cell
phone might be hey put the cell phone in
the other room
put your alarm in the other room to wake
up no put the alarm right next to you
like what's a damn doritos version of
you that you now
are ready that you now need to take
control of your life
and step into the next version of you
instead of constantly playing small and
being weak
what is damn new doritos for you number
two scary difficult or hard
try to memorize those words so that
whenever they come up
in your language in your thought process
in your writing
as a reason for you not to take action
that it's no longer acceptable
i would do that but it's too hard i
would do that but it's too scary i would
do that but it's too difficult
if you say scary difficult or hard you
have to do it now just because
just because because you do difficult
because you love hard
because you embrace scary because what's
the alternative if you never do a scary
difficult heart that means you're
staying inside your comfort zone you're
just doing things that you know how to
do
you want a life of never being scared of
never taking on difficult or hard that
means you're just doing the same thing
over and over and over and over and over
and over again and you hate your life
you'll hate your life if you're just
photocopying the same day over and over
again
so you do scary you love hard you
embrace difficult
teach yourself so whenever you catch
that in your thought process
in the words that you're using when
you're writing something out if that's a
reason if that ever comes out
if i said i would do that but it's too
hard
like just like that now i gotta do it
now i'm doing it
just because i said it was hard and that
is no longer an acceptable reason for
you
for not taking action scary difficult
part
and set number three is reward the
effort not the result we
tie our our self-worth our
self-confidence our self-love to getting
results
and you have to actually flip it most of
your entrepreneurial heroes have failed
way more than they succeeded they failed
they failed they failed they failed and
then they succeeded
you've seen the classic stories if you
tie yourself worth just to winning
what's going to happen is you're only
going to take on games that you know
you're going to win at
ergo you play small for life if you tie
yourself forth to try and put your best
effort in
every single day you may not win most
days but you're going to end up winning
way more
than if you just tied yourself worth to
winning
i use the example of running against
three-year-olds right if you ran a race
against three-year-olds you could win
right you know you win you could do it
backwards and still probably win because
they're three-year-olds
but you don't feel good about it if you
run a race
against people who are much better
people at your skill over a little bit
better
guess what's going to happen you're
going to run a faster race but you may
not win it
you run a faster race and if you keep
practicing and you keep trying
you keep putting max effort in guess
what you're going to get a lot better
so learn to tie your self-worth to the
effort you're putting in every single
day
not just the results that you're getting
if you want to change your life for
free in the next 30 days click the link
right here below or if you want some
more
animated motivation click the video
right here next to me i think you'll
enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there